du classique l'invité de guillaume
durand avec le figaro - oublié qui est
aussi maire de pau françois bayrou je
lis et je rappelle ce que le président
de la république déclarait chez notre
confrère de brut le 4 décembre dernier
peut-être que je devrais faire des
choses dures dans la dernière année dans
les derniers mois
parce que les circonstances exigent rond
et qui rendront impossible le fait que
je sois candidat
donc c'est vraiment une lucidité et en
même temps un pari phénoménal
mais tant la situation aujourd'hui cette
question elle se pose à chacun de ceux
qui est en situation d'être président de
la république qui occupe cette
responsabilité plus que cette fonction
encore parce que c'est une
responsabilité historique
j'allais presque dire écrasante dans les
moments de crise et dieu sait que depuis
quatre ans les moments de crise ont été
graves et multiples et mon sentiment en
tout cas ce que je vois en regardant
l'action et la manière de réfléchir du
président de la république c'est qu'il
ne se situe absolument pas dans une
séquence électorale il se situe dans un
moment de responsabilité et il a
parfaitement conscience que ça sa tâche
sa mission elle dépasse de beaucoup les
contingences électorales
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je le
vois vivre et réfléchir qui n'a rien
décidé et la clis et on essaie
d'interpréter ce qui est à la fois une
action une réflexion il n'a rien décidé
de ce que pourrait être son avenir
politique pourtant beaucoup disent
qu'ils ne pensent qu'à sa réélection
c'est normal c'est le cas de tous
quand occuper cette fonction mais que ce
qu'ils cherchent comme le explique que
le pignon aujourd'hui une autre histoire
à raconter et donc complété un
quinquennat que s'est ouvert par la
réforme du droit du travail ou par la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation en
koster trouver la suite tout ça cncl
parce qu'il ya eu des choses très
importantes de fait mon sentiment à moi
exprima titre absolument personnelle
bons sentiments à moi c'est que la
question de la réélection n'est pas
présentes à son esprit
la question de la nouvelle campagne
électorale n'est pas présentes à son
esprit et je vais vous dire quelque
chose je crois qu'elle n'est pas du tout
présente dans l'esprit des français mais
pas du tout ce que les français ont en
tête c'est la profondeur sans précédent
de la crise que nous sommes en train de
vivre
pas seulement sanitaire mais tout ce qui
va suivre le long cortège et que de
difficultés économiques de difficultés
sociales
les jeunes c'est ça que les français
sont en tête et
sans que le président de la république
sur ce sujet est en phase avec eux et
qu'ils ne fais pas de gestes
électoraliste il fait il prend les
décisions irréfléchies comme celui qui a
la charge d'un pays qui a la plus
importante charge dans un pays dans un
pays qui est dans une crise comme on en
a jamais rencontré l'impression ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'on va faire la
navigation parce que c'est important
entre ce qu'est la mission d'un
commissaire qui réfléchit à l'avenir et
la mission du maire de progrès
impression que chez vous par exemple
impôts les gens seraient favorables ou
comprendrait par un couvre-feu à 18
heures si ça doit faire reculer la
maladie et si ça doit empêcher leur
confinement
je pense qu'ils le comprendrait je pense
que le tout le monde a en tête cette
question qui est une question menaçante
et obsédante qui est un pays qui se
reconfigurer remet sous cloche est un
pays qu'on remet sous cloche à mon sens
ça ne doit être que le dernier recours
c'est une situation c'est une hypothèse
pour les enfants pour les familles pour
les gens qui travaillent pour tous ceux
qui sont dans la ddt dans la vie du pays
et qui emporte une part c'est une
question qui est une menace
extraordinaire pour l'instant à moi je
suis je suis me jette pour qu'on fasse
tout ce qu'on peut pour éviter leur
confinement mais je crois avoir déjà 10
à votre micro il ya quelques à quelques
mois je pense qu'un pays ne peut pas
vivre sous cloche que
les les liens les rencontres les
échanges qu'on appelle sociaux
c'est-à-dire dans la société dans notre
entourage sont une donnée essentielle
pour que les personnes les familles et
les entreprises se portent bien je vous
pose une question franche je sais qu'à
proximité qui vous lie au président de
la république depuis que vous l'avez
rejoint après le fameux voyage en
algérie où il avait tenu ces propos sur
la colonisation tout d'un coup les
sondages s'était effondré vous l'avez
ont rejoints et il est reparti à la
bataille finalement il a gagné cette
présidentielle
franchement françois bayrou ce matin à 8
heures d'un tennis que vous configurez
que ce décret du coc vide il s'est
planté
non
dont je pense que là bas parce que un il
ya les résultats sanitaires et
aujourd'hui tout le monde
il s'est passée dans dans l'esprit
public dans la conscience de nos
concitoyens quelque chose de très
important
il ya un mois ou un mois et demi au
début du mois de décembre probablement
beaucoup de français avaient en tête
l'idée que en france on n'avait pas
beaucoup de résultats mais qu'autour de
nous l'allemagne l'angleterre
les grands pays qui nous entourent eux
avaient obtenu des résultats et
française vaccination et les français
ont tout dans le coup découvert que
c'était pas vrai et que les résultats
obtenus en france étaient plutôt
meilleurs mais sa lutte au plus
rassurant pour les masques pour les
têtes je peux prédire sa 1/2 coûté oui
dieu sait que nous mêmes à pau dès la
fin du mois de février nous nous sommes
mis à chercher des masses et que nous
les avons trouvé que nous avons aidé
dans toute crise de cet ordre il ya une
part de décès et d'erreurs voilà la dite
parler d'un chemin différent c'est
justement ce que le fisc hominem
patrimoine le président de la république
finalement cette interview au journal du
dimanche d une quinzaine de jours je
croyais deux semaines après kata les
parrainages planifiant il ay on en est
là le titre c'était la colère du
président de la république ça va trop
lentement with la colère qui d'une
certaine manière ils s'adressaient à lui
même
en tout cas au chemin qui va vers le
haut aucun doute de ce point de vue là
je sais très bien que tout n'a pas été
parfait et si vous connaissez un seul
être humain ou une seule équipe d'êtres
humains parfaite présenta les mois
représentait les mois je serai très
content de rencontrer ses anges pure et
radieux comme dit le poète donc
oui mais ce que nous avons obtenu la
france est le pays du monde du monde qui
a apporté le plus d aide à ses
entreprises à ses travailleurs à ces
familles aujourd'hui sans conteste le
plus bas vous rendez compte on est un
micro d'une radio importante idées comme
vous le disiez 8h23 le pays du monde qui
a le plus aidé les siens et il a le plus
aidé des siens tout en obtenant des
résultats sanitaires dont on voit
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont au moins aussi
bon que ce qui nous entoure est sans
doute meilleur j'espère que ça ne se
dégradera pas on a devant nous cette
question de la vaccination
pourquoi est-elle essentielle parce que
la vaccination c'est le seul moyen de
réouvrir le pays
l'esprit tranquille est-ce que nous
avons des limitations sur la vaccination
ou des difficultés ou en tout cas des
éléments après oui la réponse est oui
sur un seul point qui est la
disponibilité des vaccins des doses
parce que pour ce qui est de vacciner
alors il n'y a aucune difficulté nous
avons monté nous-mêmes à pau depuis le
mois de février avec des laboratoires
nous avons monté des des rendez-vous où
on peut faire des tests instantanément
et où on a les résultats dans les trois
ou quatre heures et on en fait on a l'a
fait jusqu'à 2000 par jour donc vacciner
c'est pareil et puis il ya une autre
idée qui est évidente dès l'instant
qu'on aura des vaccins et à 22000
pharmaciens en france vingt deux mille
pharmaciens qu'on appelle d'officine
ceux qui sont au pouvoir a très bien
fait qui sont absolument habilités à
vacciner ils devront pour la grippe et
donc il n'y a aucune
aucun problème d'organisation surtout
avec le nouveau vaccin moderna qui
arrive parce qu'il a moins de
contraintes de conservation a des
températures extrêmement basses
c'est un vaccin j'allais presque dire
normal de ce point de vue là et donc il
n'y a rien de plus facile que de
vacciner mais mais la question c'est
est-ce que les laboratoires fournissent
suffisamment de vaccins et ça c'est une
question parfois industriel et médical
vous avez dit que les français étaient
conscients que l'état n'avait jamais
fait autant pour eux il ya une chose qui
est une évidence pour tous ceux qui nous
écoutent c'est qu'effectivement une
grande partie de la politique menée par
bruno le maire à l'économie est saluée
par tout le monde y compris par des gens
de gauche qui ne le disent pas
ouvertement mais qui au fond là pour en
revanche véran il ya un problème puisque
tous les patrons de région que ce soit
retourné alors c'est plutôt des patrons
de régions opposition ils sont tous
debout contre eux vers ans et parle de
scandale d'état risquent un problème
typique de la gestion de la santé puis
après c'est vrai que qu'on termine sur
une question politique parce qu'ils dans
la perspective de ce que vous pourriez
apporter c'est à dire justement la loi
sur le séparatisme la faire de
l'écologie est ce que vous êtes
favorable à ce fameux référendum qui
avait été évoquée par le président de la
république oui ce qu'il faudrait pas
mieux en matière institutionnelle
instaurer la proportionnelle pour
l'avenir des prochaines élections
commençons par veron est ce que c'est le
handicap de macron alors que le maire se
ferait son jour m'a dit je vais vous
décevoir je ne fais pas de particularité
à l'intérieur d'une équipe
gouvernementale il n'y a qu'un seul
gouvernement et une certaine manière on
peut tout le monde peut avoir des
jugements sur les ministres et le
ministre de la santé comme le ministre
de l'économie
ils sont présents et ils sont en
première ligne et personne ne pense
qu'ils sont absents évanescence par le
géant larcher dit ce quinquennat
finalement il s'est rien passé
oui mais vous voyez bien que ça c'est
des propos avec un président du crg mois
électoralement polémique donc moi je ne
veux pas jouer à ça donc je ne fais pas
de différence à l'intérieur de l'équipe
gouvernementale et c'est le etc c'est la
première question que nous avons dans
les moments de crise toute ma vie
politique je n'ai défendu qu'une seule
position
serrons nous les coudes autour de ceux
qui sont en responsabilité dans le
terrorisme vous trouverez chaque fois il
s'est passé quelque chose
c'est la position que j'ai adopté dans
la crise sanitaire de la santé c'est la
position que j'adopte la responsabilité
vous voyez à quel point c'est ridicule
les responsables qui font passer
l'opposition avant la responsabilité
vous voyez à qu'est ce qui rassemble
c'est leur rôle s'ils sont dans l'eau
polisseur qui vont prendre tous les
matins excusez moi vous dis c'est le
roller rôle dans la commande sur son
innovation démocratique excusez moi je
suis en désaccord avec vous et je vais
vous dire pourquoi quand on est dans une
guerre car c'est une gaine le président
pascal vestri c'est ce terme
quand on est dans une guerre on fait en
sorte que les liens de solidarité de
responsabilité l'emportent bogard
toute autre considération la recherche
si pendant six pendant la guerre tu
cherches il avait été en butte
perpétuellement aux critiques d'une
opposition curé dit il n'y a pas assez
de chars d'assaut ici où il n'y a pas
assez d'avions là d'où ça est ridicule
et dans les moments graves c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait alors donc donc de
ce point de vue là après vous
m'interrogez sur les institutions
référent dresser ce référendum ce qui
nous reste seize mois est-ce que ce
référendum est une demoiselle même pas
vous parler de politique politicienne
est ce que c'est une bonne affaire pour
le pays de faire un référendum en gros
sur l'écologie on ne connaît pas la
question très près où est-ce qu'il faut
pas plutôt essayer 2
de réformer le système politique par le
biais de la proportionnelle que vous
l'avez toujours souhaité une petite
question sur le passeport vaccinale et
nous en aurons fini ce matin
alors hein est-ce que la démarche du
référendum la procédure du référendum
est intéressante dans les moments de
crise ma réponse est oui il ya un
certain nombre de sujets je vais citer
les retraites
lorsque j'ai toujours défendu ce point
de vue là il ya un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels les blocages sont
telles que l'ordalie comment viser au
moyen-âge le jugement suprême
le jugement du peuple et les c est en
tout cas permet de sortir de toutes les
impasses mais vous l'a toujours penser
comme ça lâche tout risque et moi c'est
dans l'esprit un accroc ça il se rend
compte que le référendum on n'est pas
obligé comprenez moi bien
d'abord il faut que le sujet en vaille
la peine et je ne sais pas si les
modifications de textes autour de la
constitution sur l'écologie sont un de
ses sujets qui valent la peine
on en discutera si ça vient mais moi en
tout cas je dresse alors un référendum
est une bonne démarche est une démarche
utile parce que elle permet de sortir
déblocage d'un pays
deuxièmement est-ce qu'il faut changer
les institutions et en particulier la
loi électorale
oui on ne peut pas continuer dans un
pays dans lequel le parlement mais plus
représentatif au bout de quelques mois
de la situation réelle du pays
il y à une loi électorale qui est
appliquée par tous les pays européens
sans exception vous m'entendez tous les
pays des 27 sans exception utilise une
loi électorale qui est que tous les
grands courants d'opinion sont
représentés au parlement pour que
précisément le parlement ait du sens
dans qu'ils puissent se dire et faire
quelque chose et donc j'ai toujours été
favorable à cette évolution je lui fis
plus que jamais parce que c'est la loi
électorale qui permet dans les moments
de crise d'avoir aidé coalition ou et
même pas les coalitions ça fait
politiciens mais avoir du tout
en politique est normal oui mais
j'éprouvais mais nous sommes en
cinquième république et le vote majeur
c'est le vote d'élection du président de
la république c'est à partir de ce vote
du président de la république que les
institutions s'organise et que les
gouvernements se forme
ce n'est pas à partir des combinaisons
parlementaire comme chez nos voisins et
donc je suis favorable à ce connais une
loi électorale juste un seul mot
représentant le pluralisme du pays les
ceux qui ne l'écoutent ce matin retient
monde quand vous êtes falloir bon poids
un référendum sur un sujet qui n'est pas
forcément celui dont on parle d'ici la
fin du quinquennat c'est une chose
importante
dernier point ici la fin du quinquennat
vous dites ça moi je suis favorable au
référendum pour qu'ils entrent dans nos
adresses pour qu'il entre dans l'accord
ati deux gouvernements classique
vous qui aimez la musique la culture le
théâtre etc
il ya beaucoup de gens qui est de
passeports vaccinale ce serait quand
même bien pour qu'on puisse aller au
restaurant au théâtre au cinéma etc
il ya d'autres qui disent oui bah alors
c'est c'est le système à deux vitesses
face à l'éternelle question sociale à la
française ce qu'ils auront pourront
entre guillemets jouir et ce qu'ils
n'auront pas bien resteront chez eux
couvrant fin 18 heures est ce que vous
êtes favorable oui je vous savez bien
que oui j'ai défendu cette idée des tout
premiers je me suis fait j'ai ramassé
des des insultes multiples et variées
mais c'est très simple il faut ré ouvrir
le pays fort et ouvrir les universités
il faut que les jeunes puissent de
nouveau être dans des activités qui sont
les activités de leur âge faut que les
commerces ouvrent il faut que le travail
reprenne que les restaurants et les bars
ouvre comment le faire en sécurité en
s'assurant si le vaccin est garanti
efficace et sûre c'est cet interdit ce
membre de phrase est très important eh
bien oui en effet il faut ouvrir à se
vit il faut multiplier les vaccinations
et tout le monde fait semblant
ou enfin a peur ou je ne sais pas quoi
il ya des craintes qui s'expriment
excusez moi pour aller en guyane
terminez france pour aller en guyane il
faut une carte de vaccination à la
fièvre jaune pour aller au cameroun pour
aller au mali pour aller en côte
d'ivoire il faut une carte de
vaccination fièvre jaune
oui je suis persuadé que si le vaccin
est disponible alors il faut en répandre
l'utilisation et se servir de cela pour
ouvrir la vie du pays